I wanted to pick up in November 6, 1922. We've already done the first big paragraph, but
just to give it, I'm doing this for the sake of the recording. Just to give it context,
I just want to read that paragraph again. So, Louisa said, "As I was in my usual state,
my beloved Jesus made himself seen, holding many little lambs in these arms. Some were
leaning on his breasts, some on his shoulders, some were clinging to his neck, some on the
right, some on the left of his arms, and some peeking out with their little heads from
his heart." However, the feet of all these little lambs were all in the heart of the
Lord, and his breath, which of course is the Holy Spirit, was the nourishment that he gave
them. They were all turned with their mouths towards the mouth of my sweet Jesus, to receive
the nourishment of his breath. It was really beautiful to see how Jesus took highest delight,
all intent on nourishing them and delighting with them. They really seemed as many birds
delivered from his most holy heart. Then, turning to me, he said, "My daughter, these
little lambs that you see in my arms are the children of my will. Legitimate births from
my Supreme Volition." Legitimate there is that baptism makes us the adoptive children
of God, and the divine will makes us the actual children of God. They will come out from my
heart, but will keep their feet in the center of my heart. That's where you're grounded,
so that they may take nothing from the earth. In other words, you're living the highest
level of spirituality possible. So you're not taking anything from earth, you're taking
it all from heaven. And they may be concerned with nothing but me alone. Look at them how
beautiful they are, how clean and nourished they grow fed by my breath alone. They will
be the glory and the crown of my creation. And then he added, "My will crystallizes the
soul, makes us like glass, able to let the light of God through with no difficulty.
And just as when any object is placed close to a crystal, another object is formed within
it fully similar to the one which has been placed in front of it. In the same way, my
will reflects all that it does in these souls crystallized by my power. And they repeat
and they do all that my supreme will does. And since my will is everywhere in heaven,
on earth and in every place, by containing my will within them as life, wherever my will
acts, these souls absorb it like crystal within them, and they repeat my act. So as I act,
I take great delight in placing myself in front of them to see my own action being
repeated in them. They are my mirrors and my will multiplies them everywhere for every
act that it does. Therefore, there's not one created thing in which they are not present.
Fantastic, isn't it? They are present in creatures, that is in human beings, in the
sea, in the sun, in the stars, even in heaven. And my will receives the requital for my act
from the soul in a divine manner. Okay, so now I want to pick up at the second paragraph,
he wants his divine will known. Can we add to that list by putting in time? So the next
paragraph is about making the divine will known. Okay, this is also the reason why I
love so much that living in my will be known. Why? Because he wants more legitimate children
of the divine will. He wants more and more, he wants to fill his house. To multiply more
of these mirrors rendered as crystals by my will, to have my works repeated in them, then
I will not be alone anymore. And I will have human beings, the creature is always human
beings in my company. That is Proverbs 8 31, the Lord delights to be with the children
of men. And you also have Genesis three eight, where God walked with Adam in the cool of
the day, and that is a sign of his very intimate relationship with him. And I will have her
with me that that with me is in union, not just physically with intimately with me again
is emphasizing the union in the depth of my will. Now notice in the depth not in the periphery,
almost inseparable from me. Now almost I think is a very interesting word and I've
underlined it, because he describes blessed mother as inseparable to him, because she
had the divine will from conception to her passing. Eventually he said that Louisa was
inseparable from him once you get up into the 20s volumes. And that's because she had
reached the point of this being in the divine will with no return. He says almost for the
rest of us, because there's no guarantee we'll go the whole way. Is that okay? I just want
to notice the the almost there. So almost inseparable from me as if she had come out
of my womb when I created her, as if she had just sorry, come out of my womb, having followed
no other ways contrary to my will. You see, it's that having followed no other ways. See,
that's when you would be inseparable. See, that that's the position of blessed mother.
It was the position of Adam before the fall. It was the position of Louisa in her later
life. Okay, I say later. I'm not putting a date on that. Okay. And he said that he wants
us there. So how happy he would be. And then in the next paragraph, he says, and you'll
you begin to understand why he says almost. You can only take from the divine will what
you know is there. You can't take from your cupboard what you don't know is there. Right?
So you've got to actually know the divine will. So the emphasis here is on knowledge,
which is terribly important. On hearing this, Louisa said to him, my love and my life, I
still cannot convince myself. How is it possible that no saint has done your will always? See
that she's misinterpreting Don your will to do the will of God. All good Christians try
to do the will of God and all other people. And so far as they understand what they're
talking about, if they're good people, try to do the will of God. That's not what he's
talking about. He's living inside in the depths of the will. Now he lets her make these so-called
mistakes because these are our questions and to give us the answer. So how is it possible
that no saint has done your most holy will always not see always is the problem she knew
that the saints did the will and has lived in the way that you are saying in your will.
And Jesus said, am I daughter, you still don't want to convince yourself that one can take
as much light, grace, variety and value for as much as one knows. All the saints before
Louisa did not know you could live in the divine will at a divine level. So how could
they reach out for it? Surely there have been saints who have always done my will, but they
took of my will as much as they knew. Does that make sense? Okay. They knew that doing
my will was the greatest act that which honored me the most and which brought sanctification
and with this intention they did it. Okay. This is what they took because there is no
sanctity without my will. That bit needs to be underlined because if you're certainly
for teaching others it needs to be really, really underlined because there is a theoretical
possibility that someone could just read this, all this material and enjoy it and not do
the will of God. If they don't do the will of God the total waste of time. Okay. So there's
no sanctity outside of the divine will and there is no good, no sanctity, big or small
will come without it. So I want to give you my six eight, which is the Old Testament way
of saying it. This is what the Lord asks of you only this, that you would act justly
love tenderly and walk humbly with your God. I want to give you John 14, 15 and 23 or John
14 versus 15 and 23. John 14, 15 and 23. So next paragraph again is you must know the
divine will. You must know it. You must know what my will was, what it is and what it will
be. Therefore can't you see the emphasis on study here. That's the battle I have fought
in divine will circles. We must study. You must know what my divine will was, how it
has acted throughout history, what it is and what it will be. It has changed in nothing.
So as it manifests itself, it makes known the variety of colors, effects and values
that it contains. Now the colors, effects and values are all the, the attributes of God
that are manifested in a person who goes deeper and deeper into the divine will. So if you
are claiming to be living in the divine will and there is no manifestation of divine wisdom
inside of you, forget about it. Your claim is false because wisdom is the first stroke
of the brush, wisdom, understanding, counsel, fortitude, knowledge, piety and the fear
of the Lord. Okay. It's the first stroke of the brush. And if there is no love in the
actions of the person who claims to be living the divine will, they're not in the divine
will because God is love. And the two subjects that summarize the 36 volumes are divine will
and love. Okay. That's it because it's the same person. So if these two attributes of
wisdom and love are not manifesting more and more in us, then we do not have the proof
that we're actually in the divine will, we can claim it. Just as I could claim to be
a pilot, but how could I prove it? I couldn't. And but as the divine will manifests itself,
it makes known the variety of colors effects. In other words, you begin to see a transformation
in people. And it does not just make itself known, but it gives to the soul the variety
of colors, effects and values. That's like saying, we become gradually transfigured
as Jesus was transfigured in an instant. Okay. The transfiguration of Jesus was one of the
reasons was to show us what God wants to do in us and with us it has to happen slowly.
He said, and if this wasn't so, why would you make them known? In other words, he's
not just titivating our mind with ideas. He's giving something to us to change us completely.
My will acted like a great Lord who showed his most extensive and sumptuous palace.
Now, watch this number one to the first one. He's answering her question about throughout
history where there are not people who did your will. Okay. So he's answering that. So
to the first ones. So you go back in time to deal with the first saints. Okay. He pointed
out the way to reach the palace. Okay. To the second lot. So we've now moved on in history.
We showed the door to the third group. He showed the stairs to the fourth group. He showed
the first rooms and to the last ones, we're the people in the parable of the 11th hour.
Okay. He opened all the doors and you know the people at the 11th hour were paid first
and they were paid exactly as anybody else. So making the last ones, the owners and making
and giving them all the goods that are in the whole thing. Okay. Now the first ones have
taken the goods which are on the way. The second ones have taken the goods that were
at the door, superior to those on the way. The third one, those of the stairs more superior
than the people at the door. The fourth one, the first rooms and so on. And the last one,
the goods of the whole palace. In other words, he gives us everything he has. I want to give
you Matthew 1950. I also want to remind you of the mentions of St. Teresa Vavala. She says
there are six mentions. You go deeper and deeper and deeper into the mentions. Okay.
But here you're seeing not just an individual going deeper and deeper into the mentions,
but you're seeing the church over a period of 2000 years going deeper and deeper in understanding.
The interesting thing is that if you've done enough study of the divine will and go back
and read Teresa Vavala and John of the Cross, you'll realize how limited they were and yet
they were the greats of the 16th century. They were the stars of the 16th century. But
if they were only in the first rooms around the stairs, that's always that was available
to them. For example, John of the Cross wrote eloquently about divine union and that divine
union was it. But your Louisa, a teenager, when she totally surpassed him and she had
three divine unions, that John of the Cross would never ever have been able to conceive.
The church has moved on and the church has actually moved deeper. So the next paragraph
then, Jesus said, "That is what my will has done. My book says so. That is what my will
is done." It had to make known the way the door, the stairs, the first rooms to be able
to move on into the whole immensity of my will. Now that's what he's talking to Louisa
about and that's what he's making available to our generation, the whole immensity of
his will and to show them the great goods that are in it and how the soul operating in these
goods contained in my will acquires the variety of its colors of its immensity, sanctity and
power. Now watch this. You'd never have associated the words immensity. You would with sanctity
and definitely not with power with the saints of the past. Okay? It's a completely different
stage altogether. In making something known, Jesus said, "I give and I impress within
the soul that divine quality which I make known." And one of the reasons why we have
to read this stuff very slowly for ourselves is to allow the thing to happen as you're
reading it. Because to me that's what I understand about imbibing this stuff, not that I can
explain it intellectually to you, but that when I'm reading it and he says, "I give
and impress within the soul that divine quality." And I've just read what he has wanted to give.
I say, "Lord, I'm open right now." And that's exactly what he wants. That if you're open
right now to receive it, you don't have to wait another second. And even though you
don't understand fully what he's saying, that doesn't matter. He'll still give it to
you. I mean, a child, an infant knows nothing about nutrition and yet they feed very well,
don't they? It's because the mother knows about the nutrition and that's okay. And so
in that relationship the child gets everything. So the Lord knows everything. He's trying
to feed us. All we do is what the infant does is open them out and receive the food.
But I may not have said to you before that you need to just stop at that moment and say,
"Lord, this is a moment for me. This is what I want." He said, "If you knew under what
mighty waves of grace you are, when I move on to make known other effects of my will
and how as a skillful painter I paint in your soul." That's Ephesians 210, where God's
work of art, Ephesians 210. "I paint in your soul with the most vivid colors, the different
effects and values that I make known to you. You would remain crushed under my waves. You
just wouldn't be able to take it." But having compassion for your weakness, I sustain you.
And while sustaining you, I impress more within you what I tell you because if I speak, I act.
Now that really needs to be colored. If I speak, I act. And therefore the only response I can
give to this is that as I read, I open up. It's the same with the word of God. So he has
now been explaining that to us right now. And if we're open, it happens. He just gives
it here. Regardless of whether you understand it or not, it bypasses the intellect and goes
straight into the soul. So November the 8th, 1922 is about peace. Now, I should have alerted
you to this a couple of years ago, but love, joy, peace, right all over the stuff. So I
now just put a big sign that I have my love, joy, peace, patience, kindness, goodness. It's
all over this stuff. They're the fruits of the Spirit.
So Jesus says that peace without God is impossible. It's terribly important. Imagine trying to
put peace inside the British Parliament. Louisa said, "I'm going through most bitter days
because of the privations of my sweet Jesus." And if he makes himself seen, he's so afflicted
and taciturn. That means he's chastising. That as much as I may say, I cannot manage
to console him. And I remain more embittered than before. Then this morning, oncoming,
he said to me, "My daughter, the pains, the offences that people give me, are so many
that I cannot take anymore." Now, what's he talking about? The nations are banding together
to enter the field of new wars. In other words, 1922, they're already planning World
War III, and they've been planning World War II. They've been already planning World
War III for the last 20 years. If you don't believe we go on the internet, and I've seen
the whole theatre of World War III all planned out. And exactly what they want to do and
what countries they want to conquer and how they want to shift things around.
The whole plan got it on the internet about 10 years ago. So that's what he's saying
to Louisa, that he's letting her know what's already being planned quietly behind closed
doors among the people who have power. And will you hear what he thinks of them? Did
I not tell you that the wars have not ended and that the peace that is after World War
I was a false and apparent peace? Because peace without God is impossible because God
is peace. And the only time we can have peace is peace means at one with God, at one with
myself and at one with my neighbour. That's actually what peace is. At one nest. Okay.
And without that at one nest, whatever arrangement they make is only temporary. So it was a
peace, that's the first World War. It was a peace that did not come from justice. You see,
there's people doing land grabbing and all kinds of stuff. Therefore it couldn't last.
The leaders of these times, 1922, are true incarnate devils. Isn't that strong language?
Don't tell me they went to heaven. The leaders of these times are true incarnate devils who
are banding together to do evil, to cast confusion and to make slaughters and wars among the peoples.
Now that's what heaven thinks of it. And while he was saying this, I could hear the crying
of mothers, the thundering of cannons, the alarms of the cities. And I hope that Jesus
will placate himself, she says. Now she has shifted into her role of opening the kingdom
of the divine will. So her role as victim soul has gone into the background. And that's
why she says, I can do nothing about it. But she can actually, she doesn't admit the power
of the suffering of her privations. She will admit that when she gets up into the 20s volumes
that the pain she experiences is a divine pain because it's done in the divine will.
And therefore has actually got incredible power. But her own opinion of a victim soul
is I must be carrying the crown of thorns or I must be crucified or I must be carrying
the cross. That's all gone. Okay. So November the 11th, 1922, the heading I've given myself
for this one is called to live in divine will. It's the heading I've given to the whole thing.
So upon coming, my beloved Jesus drew me so very close to himself within an immense light.
Now we're in volume 14. God is light. One John one five. God is light. And the immense
light is also the divine will. The Ryan will is just from here on in it's called the light.
And you told me little daughter of my will, the immense light you see is my supreme will.
Is he okay? And from from here on in the light will be the divine will from which nothing escapes.
How can you say nothing escapes it because the divine will is present in everything,
animate and inanimate and it's preserving everything in being. You must know that as I
created the heavens, the sun, the stars, et cetera, for all, I fixed the limits, the place and the
number that they can neither increase nor decrease. Now the astrophysicist would absolutely challenge
that they would say that the universe is expanding probably is and that the number of galaxies is
increasing. It's probably the number that we are becoming able to see is increasing because we know
now there's at least a hundred million billion galaxies. And that's only I think because our
instruments allow us to see further and further. Okay, but I want to give you Job chapters 38 to 40
for the control that's in the fixing the limits. God said to Job, "Where were you when I created
the morning and when I said to the sea thus far and no further?" And it's beautiful though it's
put, it's very poetic. The number of everything is Sam 147 verse 4. The Lord has numbered everything. Okay,
and any of the scientists will tell you, the physicists will tell you that everything in the
universe can be converted into numbers, into mathematics. And the two most extraordinary
structures in the universe is a circle and a cube. They're the most perfect structures and Jesus
actually talks about them. I think it's in Volume 10. So he fixed the limits to place the number and
they can neither increase nor decrease. I hold all things as though in the palm of my hand, that's
Isaiah 49 16. The Lord holds you in the palm of his hand. Isaiah 49 16. In the same way, in creating
man, at the same time, I created all the intelligences, watch this, and each thought, all words, works,
steps, and all the rest of man from the first to the last that will exist. He created absolutely
everything. So you think you can produce an original thought? Oh, it's wonderful, isn't it?
And all the rest he said. And this was as though natural to me, why? Because he's the creator.
More so since I myself was to be the actor and the spectator. Actor is the source and the prime
mover. Okay, that's what these scholars call him. The theologian is the prime mover. And the
spectator that he would watch us actually doing it. Of even every single thought, you need to
take those words off the page, write them on a sheet of paper where you can see them, and realize
that he is the actor and spectator of all my thoughts. I better be careful, hadn't I? So two
Corinthians 10, five. Paul says every thought is to be captured and given to Christ, put under his
dominion. Okay, I also want to give you Sam 139. Lord, you know my thoughts before I think them,
you know my words before I say them. That's verses one to five, I think. So since man would not be
able to do it without me, that's John 15 five. Without me, you can do nothing. Okay. How could I
not know it? And know also their number. Therefore, all the works of the creatures swim inside of my
will just as fish swim inside a vast sea. Isn't that amazing? Okay. But actually, this thing of the
Lord knowing all our thoughts and all our desires and all our everything is good news if you're
living a holy life. If you want to live a bad life, and you want to be sort of free of God and
declare yourself an atheist and everything, it feels awfully like Big Brother is watching me,
and he is, you know, everything. That's why on the day of judgment, none of us will have a prayer,
because it won't have an excuse, because all the thoughts, and he says, he keeps everything in his
book. That's in the book of life, the Lamb's book of life, and you find that in Revelation 20 and 21,
the Lamb's book of life, he says, everything is marked there. Now for those who are living a holy
life and a divine life, he says that everything you do for him will have its compensation on the
other side, everything. But everything you do for the other side will have its consequences as well.
Next paragraph, however, having created man, not a slave, but free, because it would not have been
right. The word in my books is decorous. It wouldn't have been right for me, nor a work worthy to come
out of my hands had I delivered this man hampered and without freedom. Okay. In other words, God
wanted to create a creature that had free will, and could actually decide to have a free relationship
with him. Now, in other words, he was not interested in robots. He said, nor could I have said, let us
make him in our image and likeness. This Genesis 1 to 127, Genesis 1, 27, and Genesis 2, 7. It is
actually a quotation of Genesis 1, 27. So I could not have said, let us make him in our own image and
likeness. Notice our in the plural, and you have the hour in the in the Genesis as well. Had I not
made him free. In other words, we would not actually be like God if we weren't free. We actually wouldn't
be like him. And we wouldn't be like God if we couldn't love. And free to love is very like God.
Okay. I wanted to endow him with freedom. I was free. Free was he was to be also. Besides, there's
nothing that tortures a person more than to give a forced love. Okay. Think of all the poor women
who are forced into marriage as children, for example, which causes dividends, suspicions, fears,
and almost disgust to the one who receives it. Okay. So now he's going to talk about the origin
of thought and the redoing of everything. And he's going to bring up the subject of
seals. So that's a lot that's coming up now in the next sections. Do you see where
the act of every person, even their thought, where do you see where it has its origin? Now in the
Bible, the word origin is given as father. Abba means my origin. Okay. Where has it got its origin?
And he says that every act of the creature has its origin in the sanctity of God's will.
With this difference, excuse me, that if man wants, he can do that very thought and word or set it
well or badly in a holy way or wickedly. He's free, you see. And if there are not two ways,
you're not free. If there's only one way from here to cork, then you don't have the freedom to go
any other way. If there's no choice, there's no freedom. So he said they can he can do it well
or badly in a holy way or wickedly. Now, my will grieved, that's Ephesians 430, the Holy Spirit
grieving at our bad will. Now, my will grieved in seeing the acts of many of which it, that is the
will of God, the divine will, was not the actor. Sorry, in which it was the actor changed into
deadly acts for me and for them. Now, any act that we do, if God doesn't concur with it, you can't do
it, because he's the author and the sustainer of the universe. And what horrifies him, and if we
grasp this, it'll horrify us as well, that he allows me because I'm free to do it well or badly
with good or bad intent, okay, with grace or with wickedness. And so it is a very personal insult to
him. That's something that originated in him is turned to wickedness. Now, where did that start?
That started with Lucifer, didn't it? At the angel of light, turning all the light that was
in him into darkness, turning all the love that was in him into hatred, turning all the willingness
to serve into rebellion. Okay, that's the freedom to act one way or the other. Therefore, I wanted
that my will becoming the double actor of each act lay another divine act overall. So,
since the human race had fallen, and we were now turning acts that in their origin are holy,
turning them into evil by our sinfulness, then the Lord comes along and he lays a divine act
over that in redoing the human person in order to enable us to be able to turn back.
So that's the, he became, he becomes the double actor then because he's creator and he's redeemer.
You might like to write down creator and redeemer. Okay, so the first action was the creation
and the second one was the redemption. So that's the double act.
So a divine act is then laid over all of our acts enabling us to turn back if we want to.
And so this was to repay me with as many other divine acts according to the sanctity of my will.
So I want to give you Hebrews, it's not Hebrews. Okay, I will give you Hebrews. Hebrews 10,
and I think it's verses one to 10. And those verses Hebrews 10, verses one to 10, those verses quote
Sam 40, verses four to six. And the text that's being quoted is, you have given me a body and in
this body I will come to do your will. That's the words of Christ in the incarnation. Okay.
So he comes to do his will. So he's coming to lay this act of divine will over all our acts.
However, someone was needed to do this and here was my humanity. So the first person
to come and lay the first seal of the divine will is Jesus. The next paragraph is going to
give us the second one which is Mary and the third paragraph is going to give us the third seal
which is Louisa. And then we've got to come for the human race together and give the fourth seal
which is us. So here's my humanity, holy and free, which wanting no other life than the divine will
swimming in this immense sea went on redoubling each thought word and work of each soul and laid
and acted the divine will over it all. That's the redoing of the human race. This satisfied and
glorified the divine father in such a way that he was able to look at man and open the doors of
heaven to him in redemption. And I bound the human will more strongly leaving it always free
not to detach from the will of the Creator since detaching from it had made it fall into so many
disasters. So here the human will is made much stronger by being connected with Christ. Everything
is through him with him and in him. It's connected with Christ. He took everything into himself
and he did all the penance and the reparation for every thought word and action of ours.
So now we come to the second seal which is a blessed mother. "But I was content with this,"
he said. He was divine and human. He had to have someone that was completely human.
And then when he comes to Louisa, it's not enough to have a blessed mother because she was perfect
and sinless. So then he needed someone who was born not perfect and with original sin. And so
there's your seals. And then finally he has us who were not born any special way like a blessed
mother. And we were not given the extraordinary helps that Louisa was given were even more ordinary
ordinary and therefore you have all of these seals given to humanity to enable them to come back.
We don't know how it works but he knows and that's the important thing. Okay. So I wanted my mother,
you're having divine will acts layer upon layer laid down on the human race enabling us to turn back
to God. I wanted my mother holy. Now the word holy in the Bible is cadosh, K-A-D-O-S-H. I wanted
to give you the Hebrew word cadosh, K-A-D-O-S-H. And the reason why I wanted to do that was to tell
you that it means separated from evil. Very often when we use the word holy, we mean sort of X amount
of sanctity. Whereas the Bible means that the person is separated from evil.
So I wanted my mother holy as well to follow me in the immense sea of the supreme volition
and to duplicate all human acts together with me placing a double seal. So now you have the seal
of the God man and you have the seal of blessed mother. And they were to follow Jesus' ones because
he's divine and human. So we were placing a double seal after my own of the acts done in my will
upon all the acts of preachers. So there's the second layer. How sweet for me was the company
of my inseparable, not as inseparable mother because she never ever left the divine will.
Company in operating or working makes happiness, delight, love of tenderness, competition, accord,
and heroism arise. So there seems to have been a lot of stuff going on between Jesus and Mary.
Isolation produces the opposite. Therefore, as we worked together, myself and my dear mother,
seas of happiness and delight on both sides and seas of love arose competing with each other,
dived into each other and produced great heroism. These seas arose not for ourselves, but also for
those who would keep us company in our will, all the children of the divine will. Even more,
I could say that these seas turned into many voices which called man that is humanity
to live in our will and to give back to humanity the happiness of his original nature and all the
goods that he had lost from withdrawing our will. Okay. So the third seal is now Louisa.
Now I come to you. That's Louisa. After my celestial mother, I called you so that all human acts may
have their first seal done by me, the second done by my mother, and the third one by a creature of
common stock. Common stock means born with original sin. You couldn't say blessed mother was common
stock when she was born in the same way as Adam was. My eternal love would not be content. Now his
eternal love is Jeremiah 31 3. I've loved you with an everlasting love, and I'm constant in my
affection for you. So Jeremiah 31 3. My eternal love would not be content if I did not raise one
of their common stock, one who must open the doors to those who would dispose themselves to
enter these gates and in order to live in the divine will. Now there's Louisa being told straight
up. She is the one to open the door to the kingdom of the divine will for the rest of us.
This is the reason for my many manifestations, for the many values and effects which I made known
to you about my will. These will be the powerful magnets to draw you and then others to live in it.
However, in order to enter our will and follow the sublime flight of my acts and those of my
inseparable mother, being of common stock, you could not enter our will if you did not have,
watch this now, or had at least been transformed into the nature which came out of my hands
before man withdrew from our will. So what he's saying there, since you were born with the original
self, you could not have entered into the divine will in the way I'm asking you to do if I had not
brought you back to the point of the fall and you pick off from where Adam left off. You've got to
go beyond that's the that's why we're being brought back to the origin. So let me read that again.
You could not enter our will if you did not have or had at least been transformed into the nature
which came out of my hands before Adam withdrew from our will. That's where the Lord is going with us.
Here are then my many graces in order to restore your nature, to restore your soul to that
original state. That's the state of original innocence.
I mean no saint before Louisa has been able to conceive that at all. It wasn't possible.
As I kept giving you grace as Jesus said, I removed from you, watch this, the seeds,
the tendencies, the passions of rebellious nature. Now how the church would word that is
concup persons was removed. And if concup persons is removed then any tendency towards sin is gone.
That's the condition that people have in heaven. So you're actually living the life of the blessed
on earth. Isn't it amazing? But always leaving you free. You can always go out if you want.
Having to call you into the center of my will is to live a communal life. You're not on your own,
you're entering the very center of all things. Now anyone who has had any experience of contemplation
and aloneness with God knows that your experience is that you're in the center of the universe.
Not only are you not alone, but you're actually in the very hub of all activity. And yet you are
sitting in a chair and your mouth is shot and you are apparently doing nothing or asleep.
Because if you enter deeply into it, it looks like sleep on the outside. Okay. And so the communal
life of the Blessed Trinity is you're entering into their creative acts, their preserving acts,
everything that they're doing in others. It's absolutely incredible. That's what I mean,
but you're in the very hub of all activity. I always remember a comment of Margaret Thatcher
at one stage as you know that was yesterday. She was asked why did she persevere
in being a Prime Minister of England. It might be a good reflection considering the present lady
is now in the same position. She said, actually, she said, what is very interesting about it is
that you're in the very center of things that are happening. You are writing history. You're not
just living it. And she said, it compensates for everything. It compensates for all the trouble,
all the hassle and everything. I thought, yeah, you've said much more than you know.
Because that is exactly the position of the contemplative. You're right in the very heart of
things. You're in that place where you are actually at one with God, creating with God,
preserving with God, redeeming with God, blessing and sanctifying. You're there. You're in the
center of it. Now, when I was growing up, an image of heaven was given, which was totally wrong. And
that is you're sitting on a cloud playing a harp as if you were doing nothing. So I tried that out on
a group of teenagers once and they said they'd be so bored that go to hell for a change. Now,
they actually meant that because they need activity. And what we were not told is that you're in the
very center of everything where everything's happening. If you told them that's what heaven was,
it's like, oh, yeah, I'll go there all right. Because we all like to be in the center of where
everything's happening. You often hear young people say, it's all happening. And they get so excited
about being in the center of a very important activity. Well, that's what the divine will is.
That's what it is. You live a communal life with the divine will to make you cover all the acts by
me, which are not yet known by human beings. It was necessary to restore your nature to this happy
state. In other words, the state of the blessed. And I did this for my own propriety and sanctity
and dignity. I hate the word decorum. So I keep on trying to change it. Otherwise, you could not
have run with me. This is very interesting. In the endless acts of my will, nor you could you be
with me with that familiarity, which is needed in order to operate together. And one of the things
is fascinating about these writings is Louise's familiarity with him to the point of complaining
about him and telling you need awful patience with him and all the rest of it. That's the familiarity
of somebody who's very close to somebody else. Okay. So I want to give you Revelation 22
verses 14 and 15. Hebrews 12, 14, which I give you quite frequently. And one that I don't give you
often and I should have given it here very frequently is Isaiah 35. There are only 10 verses in it.
But Isaiah 35 is a compendium of the gospel. You start off in your slavery and you are released
and then you're put on the high road to heaven and only the saints can walk on this road.
It's the road of redemption and they're already living the life of the attitude. That's Isaiah 35.
So in this situation, the passions, the seeds of tendencies which are not good,
would have been like many bars of division between you and me. Do you see it? So they have to be
removed. At the most, you would have been at the commands of my will, like many of my faithful ones
who can actually do something that God wants to do, but they cannot be in that intimacy and actually
imitate his acts and repeat and echo him. They're not in that kind of relationship.
But you would have been very far from doing what I did and neither you nor I would have been happy.
While living in my will is precisely this, to live fully happy on earth. That's the
beat attitude of heaven on earth. And then move on to live more happy in heaven. But you have it on
earth. Now St. Elizabeth of the Trinity wrote beautifully about our relationship with the three
divine persons and said, "I am living the life of the blessed on earth." It's just that on earth,
you have to continue to suffer and redeem and again merit in heaven the suffering is over.
That's the only difference, which she was very clear about. And you can see how clear Jesus is here.
So therefore I tell you, true daughter of my volition, first happy birth from my will,
my firstborn, in other words, okay, be attentive and faithful to me. Now that firstborn of my will
means that she's the very first after our blessed lady. Be attentive and faithful to me.
Come into my eternal volition. Watch this. Number one, my acts await you. They're wanting the seal
of your acts. Number two, the acts of my mother await you. And number three, the whole of heaven
awaits you, wanting to see all of their acts glorified in my will by a creature of their own stock.
The present and future generations await you is number four. To be given back their lost happiness
and no, no, the generations will not end until man returns into my womb, beautiful, dominating,
just as he came out of my creative hands. And that's the answer to all the people who are saying,
it's the end of the world tomorrow. Okay, he says that humanity has got to come back to him
exactly as it came out of him. Well, that's not today or tomorrow. Okay, I'll just love that.
And no, no, the generations will not end until man, that is the whole of humanity returns into my
womb, beautiful, dominating, just as he came out of my creative hand. Notice the dominating he was
made Lord of the earth. But we have to become Lord, Lords of ourselves first, don't we?
So he says, I'm not content with having redeemed man, even at the cost of waiting. I will still have
patience. But he must return to me as I made him by the power of my will. By doing his own will,
he went down into the abyss and transformed himself into a brute by doing my will, he will rise and
acquire new transformations. Can't you hear Luke 15 all over the place there? That the human race
is the prodigal son. Okay, you go down into your wasteland and you've got to come back.
So by doing my will, he will rise and acquire the new transformations into the nature created by me.
Now that is the new Jerusalem, which is in Revelation 20 and 21. That's the new Jerusalem.
So he will acquire the new transformation into the nature created by me. Then I will be able to say
I have accomplished everything. That's the consummatum est of history. Now when you go to Sam 22 and the
whole description of Sam 22 gives you the internal sufferings of the Lord in so far as they knew
them at that point. At the very end, the last two stanzas, you're given the most wonderful prophecy
about the future of humanity coming back to God. It's the one place in the Bible where they actually
get this image. Now they're not talking about divine will, but they are talking about the whole
of humanity coming back to God. And he also says at the end of it, consummatum est. That's exactly
what Jesus said on the cross. It's finished, consummatum est. And so he's saying it here. I will have
accomplished it. It is accomplished is consummatum est. And he said, it's when man comes back to me
in the same way as he can. It's not a wonderful thing. And it's such a positively wonderful thing.
Therefore, people in the divine will can see over the present problems into a future full of hope,
can't you? That's Jeremiah 29 11, a future full of hope. And you see one of the things is going to be
wrong with people as we go on is that they will have no hope, they'll have no vision. And we have
to try and give them God's plan. Yeah, it's a wonderful thing. Okay, so now we come to November
the 16th, 1922. And we're going to be talking about divine works and the God first of all creates,
and then he preserves that there is two actions. Okay. And he's giving us a historical thing here as
well. So as I was in my usual state, my beloved Jesus and coming drew me all into his most holy
will, it was as if I had under my eyes all the work of creation. Now notice the deeper you go into
the divine will, the greater your vision. When Louisa starts, it's her own little bed, her own
little struggles, the little town of Corrato, and it might get out to Italy, do you know what I mean?
And then by the time she gets into the divine will, you're seeing the whole of creation,
the whole of history, because divine will is universal. And the thing that God gives you is a
universal vision and not only a universal vision of history, but a universal vision for prayer as
well. You get to the point where it's impossible to pray for yourself. Yeah, you just you just pray
in the divine will as he wants you to pray. Okay. And so I saw under my eyes all the
work of creation, and I followed all that my sweet Jesus had done for his humanity. And then,
sorry for the whole of humanity, then after we followed it together, he told me, my daughter,
my will acts in different ways. First, it operates, that is, it does the work. And then it preserves
what it has done. So the divine will create it everything and then stays in everything to preserve
it. And in creation, I operated and I ordered everything. And after I did everything, my will
remained in everything as the preserver of everything. So it's in the tree, it's in the flower, it's in
every animal, plant, rock, everything. From that time on, it has done nothing new in the order of
creation. So if we claim that something new has turned up, it's wrong. Then the second thing is
that my will entered the field again to operate. And I descended from heaven to the earth. So now
we're dealing with redemption. Number one is creation. Number two is redemption. I came to redeem man.
And my work was not for a little in creation. Creation was six days. Do you remember we were
told that? So this time is 33 years. Then again, I returned to preserve everything I did and
redemption, he sent the Holy Spirit to preserve everything in the church. Very interesting, isn't it?
Therefore, just as the sun exists, by virtue of my preserving will for the good of all and for
each one. So are the goods of redemption in act or in motion for all and for each one. So the goods
of redemption are the mass and the sacraments and the cross and the word of God and all prayer and
all the rest of it. So now he said coming to Louisa, my will wants to go back to work. This is to open
the kingdom of the divine will. And do you know what it wants to do? It wants to operate in the soul,
that which it operated in my humanity, which is absolutely amazing. This will be an extremely
long work of mine more than redemption. Now redemption was 33 years. But in redemption,
he was dealing with a God man. Okay, with us, he's dealing with poor little sinners trying to
get on our feet. So it's going to be extremely long. So there is an era of the new and divine
holiness. Humanity is not going to get on its feet immediately. Okay. And you probably know
from your own experience that you can know a good bit about divine will. It's quite another matter
to have put all of that into action and to make it part of yourself. It's one of the reasons why
I love going back to the early volumes as I realized the bits I missed. You know, and I'm
teaching it. Do you know what I mean? And really, God, that's completely new. I never noticed that
before. Do you know what I mean? And that's the value of going back over it over. I love these
early volumes. I absolutely love them. Because the later ones are sort of putting the icing on the
cake. But if you forgot the ingredients for the cake, there's not really to put icing on. And that's
why I've sent a number of people back from higher volumes to the lower volumes to get in on the
foundations again. So this will be an extremely long work of mine more than redemption. And just
as I formed a mother for myself in order to operate redemption, in whom I conceived my humanity. Now
there's your answer for someone who asks you, "How was Jesus conceived?" He said, "I conceived my
humanity." It does not say, "She conceived my humanity." Do you see that? So now I have chosen
you in order to operate what my will operated in my humanity. See then my daughter. This is about
works and works of my supreme volition. You're a bit like space, which is offered itself to let
me work. Oh dear, we really could have a long discussion about this. You need to go back to the
book of Genesis. And you're told there was nothing there. There was space for him to work. And if
he's to work in us, he needs space. And that's why in volumes one to four, he told us to put our own
will aside and to put our ego aside and to give him space. And then he moves on and he says,
"Look, will you get into your nothingness?" And then I've got the space to work. Is that okay?
And so we have to give him that space. That's the gift that we give him. So you will be like a space
which offered itself, no, notice its voluntary, in order to let me create. And to place in order the
sun, the stars, the moon and the air and so on. If you look at my side garden at the moment,
I have given space to my friend Ben to create. I have to give him time as well. But you have to
give that person space to create. And I'm looking at it and saying, Lord, you're asking us to do
that inside and to give you the time you need as well. We'd like it instantly. We'd like it
overnight. It's not going to work that way. But we have to give him the space and the time
and then he'll do it. In order to let me create and to place in order the sun, the stars, the moon,
the air, as well as all the beauty that exists in the vault of the heavens and all the good which
descends from heaven. Okay, I read that rather quickly, didn't I? Let's go back and read it slowly.
You give me the space, he says, and I will put into that the sun, the stars, the moon, the air,
as well as all the beauty that exists in the vault of heavens and all the good which descends
from heaven. That's what I'm going to put into that space. So he's going to create a new heavens
and the new earth inside of you. Now, there's loads of texts in the New Testament about the
new heavens and the new earth. Now I create new heavens and new earth. That's what he's actually
doing in Divine will. So I just didn't think of the references there. But if you just simply write
down new heavens and new earth. It's all over the New Testament. Okay. And you will be like
my humanity which never opposed what my will wanted to do. And I will enclose in you what the supreme
volition did in me so as to have its repetition. So I am a space to let him work. Is that fantastic?
Afterwards, Louisa said, I was receiving absolution. I wonder what she said to the priest.
Could you wonder? And I said to myself, my Jesus, I want to receive this absolution in your will.
And immediately without giving me time, Jesus added, and I do absolve you in my will. And as I
absolve you, my will puts the words of absolution on the way to absolve whomever wants to be absolved
and to forgive whomever wants forgiveness. This is extremely important. That if you ask the Lord
to forgive you in the Divine will, that means that forgiveness goes out to all humanity past,
present and future. Is that brilliant? What do we need more than anything else? Forgiveness.
We need this more than anything else. That's brilliant stuff. My will takes all and not one
only because you see, if we understand how God operates, it's universal.
But those who are disposed take more than anybody else. So at any particular moment,
it's the people who are more disposed to receive that gift who will receive more, but everybody
will receive something which is terribly important. So somebody who is not ready at all to forgive
will receive the first graces they need to begin disposing them to forgive. So if we keep asking
the Lord to forgive in the Divine will, then this person gets more and more and more and more help
until they reach the point of being able to forgive. That's terribly important. So we're learning how
to help people on the inside because we know that by talking to them on the outside, it doesn't do
much, does it? Okay. So November the 20th, 1922, the currents of love between God and man.
These are the emails or the telephone exchanges, the currents of love.
I was thinking, Louisa said, of how my sweet Jesus suffered many pains when he was in the garden of
Gethsemane, but not from creatures since he was alone rather abandoned by all, but from the eternal
father. There were currents of love between him and the celestial father, and in these currents,
all souls were placed. Now she told us in the, she tells us in the hours of the Passion that he had
the Passion of Love, then the Passion for sins, and then the Passion of the Jews. Do you remember?
Here she's talking about the Passion of Love. Okay. So in these currents, there was all the love
of God. You can't say God in English. That doesn't make sense. There were all the currents of love
for God for each one of them, and all the love that each of them owed to God.
And since what we owed was missing, he arrived at suffering such pains as to surpass all other
pains to the point of sweating living blood. And my Jesus, pressing me to his heart to be relieved,
told me, my daughter, the pains of love are the most excruciating of all.
See, in these currents of love between my father and me, there's all the love that all the creatures
owed me, and therefore there is betrayed love, denied love, rejected love, unknown love, trampled
love, etc. That's the most fantastic thing if you begin to really look at it. Oh, how piercingly
it reaches my heart to the point that I feel that I am dying. Okay. So you have this eternal love
going between the father and the son, and then you've got all this betrayed and sinful so-called
love on our part, and to connect us into that current of love, Jesus has to pay for it, and he
pays for it with his blood. So now we come to the currents between God and us. This is number two,
the second paragraph. You must know that in creating man, I fixed many currents of love between me
and him. Having created him was not enough for me. No. I was to play so many currents of love
between him and me that there was not to be one part of him in which these currents wouldn't flow.
So in his intelligence ran the current of my wisdom. Look at this. In his eyes ran the current
of my light. In his mouth, the current of my word. In his hands, the current of love of the sanctity
of works. In his will, the current of love for God. His own love. And so with all the rest.
Man was made to be a continuous communication between himself and his creator. Is that absolutely
unbelievable. Hence the Jacob's ladder is terribly important. That's Genesis 28.
Because Jacob saw that there had to be this communication between heaven and earth,
and he saw that it was angels. But when you go to John 1 51, Jesus said that he was the fulfillment
of that dream. That he it's through him that these currents between God and us go. And the church
actually says that all the time it's through him and with him and in him. Okay. So with sin man
broke all these currents and remains separated from me. Now the current really means a connection
between us and life and a connection between us and love. And one of the things that's very
noticeable about man in his wickedness is that he's desperately unhappy. And if you look at our
nation, just take one example, how it's more and more and more sick. That sickness is soul,
sickness expressed in its body because it's so unhappy it has broken away from love and from life.
Does that make sense? Unfortunately if you told them that they wouldn't know what you were talking
about. So he said, do you know how this happened? Look at the sun. All of its light hits the surface
of the earth and invests it so much just to make it feel its heat. So alive and real as to bring
fertility and life to everything which the earth produces. So one can say that the sun and the
earth are in communication with each other. Oh how much tighter are the communications between man
and myself the true eternal sun. Now if a human being could have the power to break
between the earth and the sun, the current of life that hits the surface of the earth,
what harm would he not do? All life would become extinct. The sun would withdraw all the current
of life into itself. The earth would remain in darkness and the fertility would be without,
the whole thing would be without life. What penalty would he not deserve? Man did this in creation
and I descended from heaven to the earth in order to reunite these currents of love.
But oh how much it cost me. And man continues with his ingratitude and returns to break these
currents repaired by me. Isn't that a wonderful way of looking at it? Now I'm going to stop there